bachelor and bachelorette ring I think  that's probably just a ball tour a  bucket and there's rings easy answer so  many fairytale ending  but what happens when inevitable while  having  [Music]  when they break up call it quits when  they sign up a bachelor in paradise like  ever do they get to keep those pricey  and me Lane rings can they go to heaven  I think we own the Rings after a certain  point we not meaning me here's what he  knows if you break up within two years  of your engagement than the ring has to  go back to production I think the iris  like looks up research makes use the  same ring for most Vanessa that rough Oh  in fact we heard it in Evans contract  does summer most of those sparklers  range from how many carats what is it  for and since most couples split well  Ben and Lauren may be big inspiring I'm  ready  [Music]